la sphère boula le parquet a requis vous
savez un non-lieu reste maintenant au
juge d'instruction à se prononcer pour
soi un complément d'enquêté
où classer la faire cette décision du
ministère public du parc et scandalise
la famille de l'ancien ministre je vous
propose d'écouter maintenant colette
boulin l'épousé de l'ancien maire de
libourne
je suis scandalisé bien entendu
laborieux des années que je suis
scandalisé et ce réquisitoire mon avocat
s'est précipitée qui a pris aussi par la
télévision s'est précipité au parquet et
a pu lire ce réquisitoire et j'ai cru
comprendre que c'était un très mauvais
roman de la part du parquet qui ne
répond à aucune des questions
essentielles car vous savez qu'il y
avait 40 anomalie les principales sont
les fractures de la face ce sont les
divinités
mon mari a été trouvé mort sur le ventre
et il avait des divinités dans le doubs
ont normalement il aurait dû le savoir
sur le ventre et puis il y a dans le
dossier il appert d'une façon formelle
que les gens qui sont allés chercher mon
mari était plein de boue avec des labos
jusqu'à mi-cuisse dans les 60
centimètres d'eau beau et bien mon mari
n'avait de bonis sur les vêtements ses
mocassins était resté à ses pieds et y
avait aucune trace de boue ce qui prouve
bien que j'ai raison qu'il a été
assassiné qu'il y avait un certain que
je ne sais pas pourquoi on les protège
et que nous qu'on nous met tout que des
entraves pour le pas que nous nous
trouvions cette vérité que nous
cherchons et que nous découvrirons je
suis formel